did you hear do at AI for developers is
GA in Google Cloud it's an AI powered
collaborator providing assistance to
help development teams build deploy and
operate applications faster and more
efficiently throughout the software
development live cycle GA means you get
to play around with it now and get this
at no cost for over a month until
February 1st it's incorporating Gemini
Google Cloud's most capable model over
the next few weeks and has tons of of
stuff to explore plus we've made videos
narrative tutorials and learning paths
to demonstrate some of the awesome
capabilities whether you're a developer
security engineer infrastructure admin
network engineer and more with more
content to come go to this link to get
started with do AI today seriously you
don't have to pay until February 1st